we are we're in San Francisco right now
we're actually heading to Muir Woods and
we're gonna take a little tour see we
can see a surprisingly never been here
before
he I was excited yeah you guys got boots
on yes we were not prepared for this
detour this is really pretty
these mice would have you seen the woods
have you seen these woods yes now walk
away okay hold up let's free off the
shot great take a walk
how's that shot school that's great shot
Janicki Thank You Jenna right up near
woods now we're heading to Golden Gate
Bridge and then off to interview
whoo-hoo Ryan Reynolds and TJ Miller
yeah you said after yeah but after this
because they flew into Oakland so he
came here and now we're going into the
city oh this is the bus do it
it's really windy we're gonna go get a
break shot old favorite
Oh
hey guys man night we're about to go
interview Ryan Reynolds and TJ Miller
pretty excited it's gonna be great
that's been asked the hard-hitting
questions I'm gonna ask a lot so hard
many questions
why not hard-hitting but for the
hardcore fan I think they'll appreciate
it if we can get a straight answer looks
awesome
I assume did on the bananas great
photography great so we're playing pool
yeah like ankle the seat we're kidding
me see ever animal decals it makes a lot
of sense would you mind starting all of
your questions but saying like I just
seen and then pressure is it okay
I just Dean was loved yes 3d prints
might alright say it like an American
invading a foreign country oh yeah I I'm
going to murder all of you what not to
know how the fan reaction has been to
set film we've been sneaking the movie
interstellar over the country we were
there oh you were there yeah we're
behind directory yeah I'm gonna ask you
if a lot of jokes that you had in the
movie you were laughing so hard
yeah Sam a lot of improper was that did
you say that he was laughing his own
joke yeah yeah okay Darren here we go EJ
often I'll are often I laugh because I
was like I can't believe that that got
into a major motion picture I feel bad
about a lot of time I feel like I'm like
I can't imagine some of the things that
I said and they were like yeah let's put
that in the movie oh I was in the Edit
really good yeah there was a lot more
yeah we put that in there was it was
other people that were like you can't
put everything he said it but it was you
know that was the fun of it was we had
so many improvised takes he's such a
good improviser that's his background
that's my background great I TJ Miller
want to say the best solution is just
think about dotnet and yeah I mean you
know because there's so much of
revelation it is when you see the movie
you're seeing that for the second or
third time that it's ever been said so
yeah with respect to yeah there's a lot
of stuff in it that I laugh at but my
favorite line is definitely Ryan's and
it is now dad oh when I grabbed Colossus
testicles yes that was a you know what
to shoot that you actually have to grab
them another man's testicles ennahdha
surprisingly agree
even though it was CGI he didn't really
need to good nice and yeah yeah yeah
let's go awesome here's gorgeous
experience colossal balls criminals down
there I saw on Twitter the other day you
posted a picture with you Jackman uh-huh
and supposedly his last Noah's brain
it's gonna be a mm sighs do you ever
think there'd be a situation where you
could sit down and talk to him and have
a brain Deadpool Crossin there's a
situation where it'll talk to him but
there is a situation where as a moderate
hostage crisis where I try to persuade
him true unblinking violence well I hope
it were no there is no greater Hugh
Jackman fan on planet earth in me not
not just as an actor but as a human
being he's he he honestly he he's so
nice he makes the rest of us look like
child murderers
yeah whereas I can't stand him because
he's more handsome than Ryan yeah oh
he's really handsome you could crack us
up our county government and a loyal
statement tight yes all I want I did
yeah I think I would love to see I would
love to see him do another Wolverine but
you know let's see I mean the role is it
just seems so it's just go ahead pool in
Wolverine would be really fun nice ago
that would be an easy lion is the
perfect it the x-men origins kind of pop
up that you had is Wade Wilson yeah I
just can see the dynamic between you two
on on screen we we had some fun together
yeah we'd love to make some beautiful
music with him so I just Dean has -
question I don't know a listen to
anything you're just confusing me what's
using your head there guys are pretty
Mario I just say my name of your site so
it's my favorite Mario Kart after this
is really good
Jimmy will probably believe you because
I know the brother and I'm we're gonna
win hey mines toad also because we're
good people we are good people Tom
Brokaw is mine that's you have to have
this cheat code for that but yeah that's
pretty good okay it's a DLC my last
question not to cut you off my apologies
is at least yeah seriously do right now
for me off in the writers bridge for me
a bit value like every single money I
mean Wilder plays yeah yeah
see another plate one day but for for
you in x-men origins you you were
introduced his wave Olson were dead yes
you it was kind of the beginning yeah
was that a role that was basically
written for you at that point was the
script about around here did you
audition or anything I didn't have to
audition but but there was no role there
was actually no roles during the
Hollywood writers strike so on the
script it says
Wade Wilson shows up talks really fast
annoys everyone so I had to write all my
own dialogue for that oh I didn't know
that that was the best part of that
movie it was fun I just was Yunan ll
kick around as he was very old Hugh
Jackman is like I'm not making it is the
most generous human being on planet so
he just lets you go he just no cure
that's his set and he just you know said
have fun and yes nice nice job but the
Deadpool part of the movie well that
sucked that was that was tough but
that had nothing to with Hugh that I
dented with me that was a higher up
studio executive decision that you know
a lot to control so thank you guys so
much for taking the time really
appreciate you guys nice to meet you
thank you thank you I don't salute your
furniture seeing the film very sure we
just got done with our interview it was
so much fun it was actually the crazies
interview ever because Matt and I were
both trying to interview TJ and Ryan
same time I'm so excited for you guys to
see the movie I think you'll absolutely
love it I can't wait to see it again are
we gonna go see it this weekend it's
February 12th not in their front why
so let's pass like that time this has
been such an awesome quick trip to San
Francisco I mean we did so many things
so right now we are at Treasure Island
and we're ending our day here and then
heading to the airport we have such a
fun day today I hope that you guys enjoy
whatever it is that we filmed right now
we're going to get some churros and
we're going to enjoy this beautiful
sunset and then we're going to fly home
and I'm going to edit this video thanks
for watching love you guys
peace out
ah
you know